this man is going into the pro football
hall of fame
this summer uh last time i saw him
was uh at nfl honors walking down a
hallway after he had just gotten the
knock on the door by david baker
and uh who knew that we would all be
quarantined uh about two months later
so his induction to the pro football
hall of fame delayed a summer
but it is still happening thank goodness
he is
uh the great isaac bruce here on the
rich eisen show how are you doing isaac
rich i'm doing good man thanks for
having me on the show today of course
absolutely uh give me your your favorite
kurt warner story he doesn't want you to
tell me
what he got oh man
he doesn't want you to tell me do any of
those exist
isaac bruce um no i think he's pretty
transparent man i mean you guys do know
that he he worked in a grocery store
right yeah we do know that
we do know that we do know that we do
know i think his nickname was flash in
high school because he was a lot it was
a lot faster
apparently that yeah i think that's what
i think that's true it might not be but
i can
happy to tar and feather him with that
regardless but
he did have a pretty decent jump shot um
you know anytime we got a way to
uh go into the cafeteria where there was
a basketball goal
yeah pretty good for you know for
quarterback shooting basketball
what was that uh uh you know they're
making a movie out of his
out of his story um and so what was that
like having a front row seat
for all of that isaac bruce back in your
day
um you know just looking at it was
pretty strange
to us the same as it was to everyone
else um
you know kind of kind of story
american-made story and
uh you know i can see uh disney
taking that whole story and making a
movie out of it uh
and you know kind of just being there to
live it and it was it was so real at
that time
and and uh fortunately we had a happy
very happy ending come out of it no
doubt about that and um
you know part of your career too of
people who've you you're gonna your bust
is gonna be
sitting in the same room as kurtz and
then one of my favorite people
on planet earth marshall falk um
when you guys got connected uh what was
your first impression of of 28 when you
first met him
isaac oh man you know what i had a
already had my impression of marshall
uh way back in his uh san diego charges
uh excuse me san diego aztec state yes
san diego state i mean every thursday
night
you know that old whack conference was
always on you know
on television and he'd be running all
over the field
and uh after that when he landed in indy
i mean
it just turned into superman and you
know i always say that
i legitimate legitimately played with
three superheroes
marshall fault isaac kim and tori oak so
those guys were awesome and marshall he
was then he was the lead way in it
hey you know i mean i i i just saw uh
tori just a few weeks ago because he was
kind enough to
run uh in my charity run for saint jude
this year
and i love that guy i think he should be
next what do you think
isaac oh absolutely man absolutely it
would have been uh much fun
for him to be uh in this 21 class uh
you know so we you know be 2021 but a
long time deserving uh had a great
career uh statistically
a great person great guy father
he just does everything right isaac
bruce here on the rich eisen show what
do you think the lasting legacy of the
uh the greatest show on turf
is what we're seeing today honestly
there's no there's no
um there's no ending punctuation
uh behind it right now because when you
look through the league
uh you still see a lot of teams a lot of
offenses
attempting to you know duplicate what we
had uh
either from a philosophy standpoint or
you know if they could manufacture the
personnel that we had
on that level so they like throwing it
around and i think uh you know what mike
martz brought to the team and
uh his expertise and and his confidence
uh just resonated through the league and
people are still trying to duplicate it
who's trying to duplicate it what do you
see when you turn on a television on a
sunday or a thursday or a monday
what are you seeing what's your
personality your personnel groupings
from from
three wides four wide empty backfields
um the combinations um i can i can sit
back and just
uh really just name the route
combinations from from the start of the
snap
and uh the names may be changed but
most definitely they're pretty much a
lot of stuff that we ran
you know i like to say that we perfected
when we played isaac bruce
class of 2020 finally going into the
hall of fame here in 2021
knocking on wood uh pro football hall of
famer
from the st louis rams and yes even the
los
angeles rams because that's how you were
drafted into the league correct by the
chuck knox
anaheim based los angeles about to move
rams correct
i thought yes sir check knocks 1994
uh the first round just picked of that
year uh wayne gandy out of auburn
tackle and i was a second round pick
1994 right in anaheim so um
uh after spending two years in junior
college in southern california came
right back to the rams but had a great
time right here man so
here we are again
what was that like for you though uh
south florida kid who did
play a couple years uh to get to the
university of memphis and then get
drafted
uh play a couple years in southern
california what was that like for you to
be thrown into that and then suddenly
you're a saint louis ram and
all of that was going on for you in your
career
isaac well well i i definitely took the
unconventional route as far as getting
to get into college but once i came here
in uh in southern california i'm
currently here in southern california
right now
um it was special man it was it had the
the same type melting pot that i grew up
in in south florida
uh they had a sun that was shining all
the time but the humidity
minus the humidity that i grew up with
in south florida but uh just the people
itself man the culture here
uh was different and and i enjoyed every
minute of it
and was it difficult for you to just
actually focus on your craft and get
get get uh get get what you need to get
done when
all this other stuff was going on with
the franchise the team the move the
locations and
stuff like that for you well i was uh i
was in a good place to have
uh really good coaches coach marks when
he was on the staff at that time and
uh right after the move he had become
become my
position coach he was the wide receiver
coach and
i had great veterans that were in the
room with me flipper anderson
uh jesse hester uh guys who could really
help me develop so
i think i benefited from those those
people being around constantly
and really just focusing in on uh
becoming a better football player um you
know having moved around from
south florida to los angeles so i was
kind of used to moving
but at the same time i just had that
stability of those guys who
were willing to help me and to help me
develop isaac bruce here
on the rich eisen show julio jones is
now a tennessee titan how do you think
that's gonna work
uh isaac with him and aj brown a second
year
third year player now they're all
they're all with derek henry as well how
do you see that offense playing out now
that julio has joined
the mix there well julio is awesome
he's always been awesome from his days
in uh at alabama
and everything he's done in the league
thus far uh
just uh partnering up with uh aj brown
which i who i feel is a
another legit receiver in this league um
i think the pressure is definitely on
tannehill now because um you know with
the weapons that he has outside
uh and and the big derrick henry that's
behind him
um you know i guess teams are going to
come out and try to stop tanner hill
and make him have to completely beat
them as opposed to
you know the way where it has been which
you had to turn around and just handing
derek henry the ball
you know 20 plus times 25 plus times a
game so maybe that defense starts to
really focus in and try to
uh force cannon hill to beat them
instead of what you what you had
previously
so who's the best receiver in the game
the one that you'd put your isaac bruce
harder and american dollars down to sea
who would that person be
currently in the nfl isaac
i still like hopkins uh over in arizona
i think he's a special talent
uh julio went healthy he's definitely
special um maybe
maybe probably two or three guys that i
pay to watch
uh uh play football play the position
but you know i think the league is full
of a lot of great talented guys got up
and coming guys every year it seems like
we have a guy
as that seemingly comes out of nowhere
and really just
hops right into that upper echelon of uh
top five wide receivers in the league so
i'm excited about seeing who that guy
will be this year yeah i mean d hump
he's just it always seems to me isaac
that uh his catch radius
is you know almost uh
superhuman and i i've never seen him
come
when he's gotta you know tiptoe the
sideline he's gotta do the toe drag swag
or anything
i've never seen his foot out of bounds
ever
it's always he he he's got an uncanny
sense of where he is on the field
uh uh and how how do you how does one do
something
like that you know uh repetition yeah
through repetition
uh you know being able to uh control
your body movements
um i don't think he's the biggest guy uh
but at the same time you know
it takes it takes hours of repetition
these otas that we
that we see these guys going through
right now in the mini camps and
uh spending time alone just practicing
it so
when the opportunity presents itself in
a game you know it seems second nature
but um he's truly a great great talent
man i love watching him play and i love
uh you know when he has to hook up with
the jalen ramsey's of the world
and those guys battle each other man
those those are awesome to see i know
who you're rooting for there how do you
how do you see how do you see stafford
playing out in this offense
for the rams in los angeles oh man it's
like a breath a breath of fresh air i
think uh not only for
stafford but you know for the rams
offensive unit as a whole
um i think uh you know with with his
addition i think
that offense is ready to you know kind
of see
what we saw in 2018
uh in the early part of 2019 and i i
mean
you know throwing the ball down the
field taking the top off the defense
and uh you know a lot less you know
passes behind the line of scrimmage and
and uh you know dinking and dunking so i
think
with his addition man he he'll have that
mentality along with sean mcvay
just to throw the ball down the field
how much contact do you have with the
current la rams and mcveigh and
everybody isaac
um you know i'm actually going to
practice today so that's contact
i would say maybe i get a chance to meet
coach mcveigh for the first time
you've never had is that true i haven't
i mean it's just you know
things that just happened just hasn't
happened but uh
you know maybe it happens today but i'll
be around the guys today and
and and it's always it's always a great
feeling when you can go to practice and
really don't have to participate so
i enjoy that okay well uh mcveigh's the
guy who talks fast
uh he's he looks young uh right here and
he yeah he's got great hair
just look for look for that guy that's
the guy nice hair oh
please i'm jealous i'm not gonna lie um
yeah they were showing a picture of him
right there yeah
um so uh before i let you go the isaac
bruce foundation
sweepstakes pro football hall of fame
and triumphant giveaway what's that
about
isaac man it's a cool deal man we've uh
partnered with uh
let's engage dot com slash isaac
and uh it's an opportunity for fans to
win
uh a grand prize of a two-round trip air
fight air flight
air airfare tickets to canton to see the
induction a three-night stay hotel
uh two tickets were sold out
pre-enfirement tailgate
and all of it you know it's for ten
dollars to enter into the sweepstakes
and it goes towards
isaac bruce foundation my flight 300
program and we provide transportation to
college bound students in need
and uh we haven't turned anywhere anyone
away since 2006
so um it's a great deal great cause
it'll be a lot of fun
and can how can people get involved in
that
they can find all information on
lessengage.com
isaac okay and just enter the
sweepstakes for ten dollars and uh they
get an opportunity to win the grand
prize the grand prize is just to hang
out
and uh and be a personal guest of isaac
bruce at the
enshrinement ceremony that's coming up
um that's planned for
this summer um so isaac how does your
bust look i imagine you've
still not seen it because i mean it's
been a year plus you still it's still
gonna be a reveal when you see it um
it's gonna be revealed it looks
it looks really good um we did uh the
uh sizing and everything down in miami a
couple years ago
but the actual uh uh
makeup of it and we did via zoom which
you know which was kind of hard uh so i
really haven't seen the finished product
but
um you know from everything i saw it it
kind of looks like me kind of looked
like my older brother a little bit okay
um i'm sure it'd be a nice surprise is
it smiling
is it smiling isaac bruce or all
business isaac bruce is it young isaac
bruce is it super bowl grizzled isaac
bruce what do we have what do you think
what do we have i think it's the it's
the young isaac bruce none smiling
pre-game let's go play isaac bruce okay
you're focused
i got i like it um also who is uh
presenting you at the hall um i have uh
tony wiley he's presenting me along with
my brother samuel bruce the one who i uh
fell in love with football uh watching
him every day
go out and play and uh his little league
journey
and his high school journey so those
would be the two guys that i'll have uh
participating with me okay and you know
you've been waiting a long time
not just um this last year but your
entire career
so i say that um leading up to
this and i fully understand this is
about me
okay isaac i'm so sorry but there's an
iron rich and
eisen uh so i understand this is about
me
there's a lot of people talking a lot of
people
i mean you got the centennial class you
got the your class
oh yeah i know that there's they're
they're i think this centennial class
might have been handled before
i don't know what the protocol is but
then there's 2021
also so i know you're you've been a man
of few words
your entire life i mean that's part of
your mo you're you're quiet you're
reserved you let your play do the
talking um
can you can you can you be that guy when
it's time to talk
uh in august isaac how how long's your
speech
what do you got for me uh absolutely um
you know i i feel like my words are more
impactful um so therefore
when it's time to speak i'll definitely
have something to say
but i think they're giving us about
eight minutes of peace
as far as the speeches are concerned
please eight minutes
eight minutes eight minutes yeah i may
be at a probably
between 10 and 15 minutes so it may
stretch just a little bit long but
i'll try to honor you know what's been
asked of us no okay no no look
10 15 minutes i would literally sign for
that right now they were getting a
poor curt curt the year that he went in
he got up there it was like a quarter
after 11 at night because people are
going like 38 40 minutes
and uh you know like we can't you know
isaac i'll sign for that
i i don't i'd put you on hall of fame a
long time ago if i'd known that
oh my gosh i should have uh i should
have had you be
my my presenter yeah election committee
i could pound the table
right i'll i will always pound the table
for you um
know this i've been around marshall and
kurt a long time they
love you man and they were always
pounding the table on your behalf or
speak glowingly of you every single time
that your name came up but i'm sure you
already knew that but you deserve to
hear it so
um congratulations on everything thank
you man i feel that philly is definitely
mutual man thank you for having me
i appreciate it let's do this uh as the
day uh approaches that uh isaac bruce
let's do it
thanks again let's do it man you got it
super bowl 34 champ class of 2020
inductee finally getting
his day in the sun figuratively and
literally isaac bruce here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here